Katrina:  多少钱一次啊这是
Katrina: How much is it per try, anyway?
其他人：不划算啊
Katrina:  还不如直接买呢
其他人：对
Katrina:  厉害吧
Katrina:  老板嘞老板嘞
Katrina:  这个也好看
Katrina:  哎好软啊这个
Katrina:  （歌词）耳朵借我
Katrina:  里面还有
Katrina:  我去我之前在游乐园也也这么多
Katrina:  哎他们人呢
Katrina:  这要10个币
其他人：哦好贵啊
Katrina:  他们不在
其他人：我只知道修硕一直在那里
Katrina:  嗯哈哈哈
Katrina:  showtime修硕的show time
Katrina:  他们会不会在这边
Katrina:  老板丢喽
Katrina:  还有币啊
Katrina:  玩游戏去
Katrina: Let's go play games.
Jake: 这是我们现在唯一的成果对吧
Jake: This is our only result so far, right?
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 可以还有8个
Jake: Okay, we still have 8 more.
Alice:三眼仔
Alice: The three-eyed one.
Katrina:  玩个那个去
Katrina: Let's play that one.
Katrina:  去不去玩那种打打打杀杀的
Katrina: How about playing something with fighting and shooting?
其他人：打枪的
Others: The shooting one.
Katrina:  对刚刚那人他们在玩
Katrina: Yeah, the one they were playing earlier.
Katrina:  咱4个够吗哈哈
Katrina: Are the four of us enough? Haha.
Katrina:  哦这个这个
Katrina: Oh, this one, this one.
Katrina:  这有人吗
Katrina: Is anyone here?
其他人：没有
Others: No.
Jake: 你们要打这个
Jake: You guys want to play this?
其他人：十个1币不够了
Others: Ten coins aren't enough.
Jake: 不够了哦不够
Jake: Not enough, oh, not enough.
Katrina:  不够啊 10个币
Katrina: Not enough? 10 coins.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Jake: 再抓一个
Jake: Let's grab another one.
Katrina:  啊居然要10个币
Katrina: Ah, it actually needs 10 coins.
Katrina:  太贵了吧
Katrina: That's too expensive.
其他人：太贵了10块钱玩一次
Others: It's too expensive, 10 bucks per game.
Katrina:  这是北京的物价吗
Katrina: Is this the price in Beijing?
Katrina:  还是说时代变化才涨价啊
Katrina: Or is it inflation over time?
Katrina:  修硕那个架子鼓多少钱啊要20吧
Katrina: Shure, how much is that drum set? 20 bucks?
Katrina:  不会吧
Katrina: No way.
其他人：估计也是十个
Others: It's probably ten too.
Katrina:  应该10个吧
Katrina: It's probably ten, right?
Katrina:  20 这没得玩了
Katrina: If it's 20, we can't play anymore.
Katrina:  那我们去找哪一个嘞
Katrina: So, which one should we go for?
Katrina:  嗯这种会比较难
Katrina: Hmm, this one is a bit tricky.
Katrina:  然后他表面比较光滑
Katrina: And it's quite smooth on the surface.
Katrina:  抓这个
Katrina: Grab this one.
Katrina:  对呀很软的
Katrina: Yeah, it's really soft.
Katrina:  抓他
Katrina: Grab it.
Katrina:  抓3个币
Katrina: Grab three coins.
Katrina:  算
Katrina: Okay.
Katrina:  只玩两个的
Katrina: We'll just play two rounds.
其他人：哦这要四个币
Others: Oh, this needs four coins.
Jake: 打一架
Katrina: 这两个
Katrina: These two.
Katrina:  其实这也还行
Katrina: Actually, this one’s alright too.
Katrina:  但是我怕这个很瘪
Katrina: But I’m afraid this one will deflate.
Katrina:  他一松就掉
Katrina: It'll fall off as soon as it loosens.
Katrina:  这好看但是
Katrina: This one looks nice but...
其他人：给他凑成一对
Others: Pair it up for him.
Katrina:  哈
Katrina: Ha!
Katrina:  抓哪个呢
Katrina: Which one to grab?
Katrina:  那个还是这个
Katrina: This one or that one?
其他人：可以这个
Others: This one will do.
Katrina:  往这来
Katrina: Come this way.
其他人：往那边啊对
Others: Go that way, yeah.
Katrina:  啦
Katrina: La.
Katrina:  啦啦
Katrina: La la.
Katrina:  怂的很
Katrina: So timid.
其他人：啊没关系
Others: Ah, it’s alright.
Katrina:  没事已经有一个
Katrina: No worries, there's already one.
Katrina:  他他他他
Katrina: He he he he...
Katrina:  有一个这样的脚就很容易松下来
Katrina: One leg like this makes it easy to loosen.
Katrina:  你要对他进行受力分析
Katrina: You need to analyze the stress on it.
Katrina:  嗨啊
Katrina: Hey!
Shure:  飙一下吗
Shure: Wanna race?
Shure:  飙车吗飙车
Shure: Wanna race? Race the cars?
Katrina:  飙车你有多少币
Katrina: How many tokens do you have for racing?
Shure:  我正好4个应该
Shure: I think I have just 4.
Katrina:  4个能够飙吗
Katrina: Is 4 enough to race?
Katrina:  好像十个哎
Katrina: Seems like you need ten.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina:  啊你去看看
Katrina: Ah, go check it out.
Shure:  不是4个吗
Shure: Isn't it 4?
Katrina:  我想着四五块差不多了是吧
Katrina: I thought four or five tokens should be enough, right?
Shure:  我在家老玩那个
Shure: I always play that at home.
Katrina:  对就那边那个
Katrina: Yeah, just over there.
Shure:  对啊就是那边那个
Shure: Yeah, right over there.
Shure:  那个湾岸是吧
Shure: That Wangan game, right?
Jake: 哈哈哈你你这个不亮了
Jake: Hahaha, this one's not lighting up.
Jake: 你这你这没电了吗
Jake: Is it out of power?
Shure:  还有五五个
Shure: There are still five.
Shure:  飙一下这个
Shure: Let's race this one.
Jake: 这个是多少钱
Jake: How much is this one?
Shure:  五个一次
Shure: Five tokens per race.
Jake: 这么多啊
Jake: That many?
Katrina:  我靠 40元
Katrina: Damn, 40 yuan.
Jake: 感觉凑这边还有两个
Jake: Seems like there are still two more here.
Jake: 谁要跟他飙
Jake: Who wants to race with him?
Katrina:  够标吗不够了
Katrina: Is it enough for a race? Not enough.
Shure:  这只有5个
Shure: We only have 5.
Shure:  不够了
Shure: Not enough.
Jake: 五个现在总共凑不出来了
Jake: Five isn't enough to gather now.
Katrina:  玩这小机子呢
Katrina: Playing this small machine.
Shure:  哈哈哈1币一次
Shure: Hahaha, 1 token per play.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  这好玩
Katrina: This is fun.
Katrina:  这是自己单人打是不是
Katrina: Is this for single-player?
Katrina:  哎这是4币
Katrina: Hey, this is 4 tokens.
Shure:  但是我们只有7个
Shure: But we only have 7.
Katrina:  哦
Katrina: Oh.
Shure:  哦那边3币
Shure: Over there, it's 3 tokens.
Shure:  来来那个来那个
Shure: Come on, let's do that one.
Shure:  那个给我飙一下
Shure: Let me race that one.
Jake: 这个可以吧
Jake: This one should be fine.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Jake: 围观大围观
Jake: Everyone gather around.
Katrina:  给我一个币
Katrina: Give me a coin.
Katrina:  3个是吧哦
Katrina: It's three, right? Oh.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha
Katrina:  这怎么玩啊
Katrina: How do you play this?
Katrina:  我看看就左右开车会开
Katrina: Let me see, just steer left and right, right?
Shure:  车会开吧
Shure: You can drive, right?
Shure:  车会开那就一样了
Shure: If you can drive, it's the same thing.
Katrina:  哪是刹车
Katrina: Which one is the brake?
Jake: 会开车吗
Jake: Can you drive?
Katrina:  会开哈哈
Katrina: Yes, I can drive, haha.
Katrina:  哪是开车啊
Katrina: Which one starts the car?
Jake: 怎么还有怎么在拍我啊
Jake: Why is someone still recording me?
Jake: 啥意思
Jake: What does that mean?
Katrina:  请把获取的二维码放来
Katrina: Please place the obtained QR code here.
Jake: 为什么都在拍我呢
Jake: Why is everyone filming me?
Jake: 呵呵干嘛
Jake: Haha, what's up?
Jake: 这个地方
Jake: This place...
Katrina:  不知道啊
Katrina: No idea.
Katrina:  哪个是刹车和哪个
Katrina: Which one is the brake and which one...
Jake: 这这相机是
Jake: This camera is...
Jake: 啊
Jake: Ah
Jake: 你得到这注册一下还是这个意思是吧
Jake: Do you need to register or something like that?
Shure:  对但是可以不注册
Shure: Yeah, but you don't have to register.
Jake: 是上车之前拍个照
Jake: Take a photo before getting in the car?
Jake: 然后再上车
Jake: Then get in the car.
Jake: 考驾照啊
Jake: Is this like a driving test?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  这为啥一直要那个
Katrina: Why does it keep asking for that?
Shure:  你直接开始跳过对
Shure: Just skip it and start.
Jake: 就开始开始呗开始
Jake: Just start, start.
Katrina:  向上拉动扣子
Katrina: Pull the lever up.
Katrina:  使用方向盘速度
Katrina: Use the steering wheel for speed.
Shure:  当然是开我的AE86了
Shure: Of course, I'm driving my AE86.
Katrina:  哎我喜欢这个
Katrina: Oh, I like this.
Shure:  然后选那个店内对战
Shure: Then choose the in-store battle.
Katrina:  自动挡哈哈
Katrina: Automatic, haha.
Shure:  啊选那个店内对战
Shure: Yeah, choose the in-store battle.
Katrina:  哪啊
Katrina: Where?
Shure:  往往往右往右往右对对
Shure: Turn right, right, right, yes.
Katrina:  这个
Katrina: This one?
Shure:  然后开始
Shure: And then start.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Katrina:  是不是只要踩油门跟刹车
Katrina: Is it just the gas pedal and brake?
Shure:  对对
Shure: Right.
Katrina:  对这不用弄是不是
Katrina: I don't need to do anything else, right?
Jake: 币用光了吗
Jake: Are we out of coins?
Jake: 还是还有
Jake: Or do we have more?
Jake: 还有最后一个
Jake: We have one last one.
Shure:  还有最后一个
Shure: We have one last one.
Katrina:  还有一个
Katrina: There's one left.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 还有一个币
Jake: One more coin.
Jake: 能干嘛
Jake: What can we do with it?
Shure:  为什么他这这么慢啊好
Shure: Why is he so slow? Alright.
Jake: 路亚那边有几个币他人呢
Jake: How many coins does Loya have over there? Where is he?
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey.
Katrina:  我现在搞不清哪个是刹车
Katrina: I can't tell which one is the brake.
Katrina:  哪个是油门啊
Katrina: Which one is the gas?
Katrina:  啊哈哈
Katrina: Ahaha.
Katrina:  哇这被超了
Katrina: Wow, I got overtaken.
Katrina:  撞了你哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Crashed into you, hahaha.
Shure:  弯道快才是真的快
Shure: Speed in the curve is the real speed.
Katrina:  我靠
Katrina: Oh my.
Katrina:  哇漂移啊你们
Katrina: Wow, you guys are drifting.
Katrina: 我靠
Katrina: Oh my.
Katrina:  啊哈哈哈哈哈走
Katrina: Ahahaha, let's go.
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow.
Lucia:  还有谁要玩的吗
Lucia: Anyone else wants to play?
Katrina:  只能玩一个人
Katrina: Only one person can play.
Katrina:  3个
Katrina: Three.
Shure:  还有几个币的
Shure: How many coins left?
Lucia:  给我这还有我还可以再再开个车
Lucia: Give me, I can drive again.
Lucia:  所以如果有人要玩的话可以再玩一局
Lucia: So if anyone wants to play, we can play another round.
Shure:  他可以再这个
Shure: He can go again.
Katrina:  你玩呗
Katrina: You play then.
Shure:  因为他赢了
Shure: Because he won.
Shure:  他是不需要再投币子的
Shure: He doesn't need another coin.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah
Shure:  所以如果想玩的话可以再来一次
Shure: So if you want to play again, we can.
Shure:  杨老板要试试吗
Shure: Jake, do you want to try?
Shure:  再来一局就是
Shure: Let's play another round.
Lucia:  那我跟你再来一局哈哈哈
Lucia: Then I'll play another round with you, haha.
Katrina:  那你俩玩
Katrina: You two play then.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 这你还可以续一局是吧
Jake: You can continue another round, right?
Jake: 哦你无论如何都有一局
Jake: Oh, you always get one round no matter what.
Lucia:  嗯然后呢
Lucia: Yeah, and then?
Jake: 你那个币是怎么花的呀
Jake: How did you spend that coin?
Jake: 可以捐了一毛
Jake: You can donate a dime.
Shure:  你已经投了3个BG
Shure: You already invested 3 BG.
Lucia:  然后我按开始吗
Lucia: Then I press start?
Shure:  对你按开始
Shure: Yes, press start.
Jake: 现在还剩几个呀不剩了
Jake: How many are left? None.
Shure:  你们你们
Shure: You guys, you guys.
Shure:  谁要再来一局
Shure: Who wants another round?
Katrina:  我来我来
Katrina: Me, me.
Shure:  还有人要来一局吗
Shure: Anyone else want another round?
Katrina:  我来了
Katrina: I'm here.
Katrina:  你不玩吗不玩
Katrina: Aren't you playing? No?
Shure:  我不玩了先
Shure: I'm not playing now.
Lucia:  然后呢我现在我现在干嘛
Lucia: So, what do I do now?
Katrina:  你们不玩吗
Katrina: Aren't you playing?
Lucia:  他为啥要让我用微信
Lucia: Why does he want me to use WeChat?
Lucia:  开始
Lucia: Start.
Katrina:  不用微信
Katrina: No need for WeChat.
Katrina:  直接star star就行
Katrina: Just press start.
Shure:  坐我这边是手动
Shure: Sitting here is manual.
Katrina:  手动挡吗
Katrina: Manual transmission?
Katrina:  什么手动挡啊
Katrina: What manual transmission?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes.
Katrina:  手动挡我都忘记怎么开了
Katrina: I forgot how to drive manual.
Shure:  先放到一档
Shure: Put it in first gear first.
Shure:  啊不不不
Shure: Ah no no no.
Shure:  点这个啊
Shure: Press this.
Shure:  完了完了点错了
Shure: Oh no, pressed the wrong button.
Lucia:  咋这样吗
Lucia: Like this?
Shure:  啊你我靠
Shure: Ah, you... damn it.
Shure:  能返回吗
Shure: Can we go back?
Shure:  完了他返回不了了
Shure: Oh no, he can't go back anymore.
Katrina:  不是已经搞到6了吗
Katrina: Didn't we already get to 6?
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Katrina:  爽了
Katrina: Feels good
Jake: 好你还有
Jake: Okay, you still have some.
Lucia:  是我就随便按一下
Lucia: If it were me, I'd just press it randomly.
Shure:  走啊没了
Shure: Let's go, it's over.
Jake: 哎啊没了
Jake: Oh no, it's over.
Shure:  走啊走
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Jake: 收获满满
Jake: We gained a lot.
Katrina:  哈哈床上有东西装饰
Katrina: Haha, there's stuff for decoration on the bed.
Shure:  就他抓到了是吗
Shure: Did he catch it?
Jake: 对还好还好有个东西证明我们来过
Jake: Yes, luckily we have something to prove we were here.
Jake: 不然这一段可能就连不上
Jake: Otherwise, this part might not connect.
Jake: 对对对然后问这哪来的对
Jake: Right, right, then they'll ask where it came from.
Katrina:  咋了还有哇
Katrina: What's up, there's more? Wow.
Jake: 还有还有三个
Jake: There are still three more.
Lucia:  可能因为我一直都在玩那些游戏
Lucia: Maybe because I've been playing those games all the time.
Lucia:  花的时间很久
Lucia: It took a long time.
Lucia:  所以他现在还有三个
Lucia: So now he still has three left.
Jake: 呃那边还有一个保龄球一块钱
Jake: Uh, there's still a bowling game for one dollar over there.
Jake: 玩了很久
Jake: Played for a long time.
Jake: 因为前面有个人投了两个币
Jake: Because someone put in two coins earlier.
Jake: 还剩一个就可以玩
Jake: There's one left, so we can play.
Lucia:  啊
Lucia: Ah
Jake: 然后我们在钱生钱这这这这这这
Jake: Then we make money from money, this, this, this, this.
Tasha:  我也想玩节奏大师来着
Tasha: I also want to play Rhythm Master.
Jake: 2/3
Jake: 2-32-3呢有个神仙有个菩萨
Jake: 2-3, 2-3, there's a deity, a Buddha.
Shure:  因为有有一个人投了两个
Shure: Because someone put in two.
Jake: 有个菩萨之前
Jake: There's a Buddha from before.
Tasha:  这个刚刚是也投了俩
Tasha: This one also put in two earlier.
Jake: 对这个也是2/3
Jake: Yes, this one is also 2/3.
Jake: 这也是2/3
Jake: This one is also 2/3.
Lucia:  哦
Lucia: Oh
Lucia:  神奇
Lucia: Amazing
Lucia:  谁先来
Lucia: Who's first?
Shure:  谁先来我试试
Shure: Who's first? Let me try.
Jake: 来了
Jake: Here we go
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive
Lucia:  哇居然是现实和屏幕结合
Lucia: Wow, it's a mix of real life and screen
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Lucia:  哇厉害
Lucia: That's amazing
Shure:  strike
Shure: Strike
Jake: 来你还有一个
Jake: You have one more
Katrina:  火鸡大奖
Katrina: Turkey grand prize
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Impressive
Shure:  练过的
Shure: Practiced
Jake: 练我
Jake: Train me
Jake: 可以好下去吧
Jake: Alright, you can continue
Shure:  好然后呢
Shure: Okay, then?
Jake: 哈哈哈换下一个
Jake: Haha, next one
Jake: 要拿要帮你拿东西吗
Jake: Do you need me to grab something for you?
Jake: 来
Jake: Here
Jake: 对就越中间越好
Jake: Yes, more to the center
Jake: 你还有5秒钟
Jake: You have 5 seconds left
Lucia:  好像不是那么中间
Lucia: Doesn't look that centered
Jake: 那还你还有一次机会
Jake: You have one more chance
Jake: 你可以往左边打一打
Jake: You can aim a bit to the left
Lucia:  然后呢他会哎
Lucia: And then he will...
Jake: 球来了
Jake: Here comes the ball
Lucia:  哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK
Tasha:  补中
Tasha: Spare
Jake: 哈哈哈好
Jake: Haha, good
Jake: 来吧
Jake: Go ahead
其他人：哇
Others: Wow
Jake: 上火鸡就一次
Jake: You only get one shot at turkey
Jake: 全砸中就有个火鸡
Jake: Strike all pins and you get a turkey
Jake: 哈哈没关系这左边右边都没有差别
Jake: Haha, no worries, left or right doesn't matter
Tasha:  啊我比你厉害哈哈哈
Tasha: Ah, I'm better than you, haha
Jake: 比你还多比你还多比你还多
Jake: More than you, more than you, more than you
Katrina:  这模拟的不是他
Katrina: This simulation isn't him
Katrina:  想想想开多少就开多少
Katrina: Imagine as much as you want
Jake: 越歪分越高你知道不
Jake: The more off, the higher the score, you know?
Jake: 来来来来来来
Jake: Come on, come on, come on
Katrina:  我来吗
Katrina: My turn?
Katrina:  咿呀
Katrina: Yay
Katrina:  就丢吗哎呀哈哈哈哈哈哈哈啊
Katrina: Just throw it? Ahaha, haha, ah
Shure:  你这好随意啊
Shure: You're so casual about this.
Jake: 哈哈手滑了
Jake: Haha, slipped my hand.
Jake: 还有还有还有
Jake: There, there, there.
Katrina:  太搞笑了
Katrina: That's hilarious.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  是一个很随便的人
Katrina: You're such a casual person.
Katrina:  还有吗球来了
Katrina: Is there more? The ball is coming.
Jake: 球球来了
Jake: The ball is coming.
Jake: 球已经来了
Jake: The ball is already here.
Katrina:  哦哦已经来了
Katrina: Oh, it's already here.
Katrina:  OK这也可以
Katrina: OK, this works too.
Jake: 可以
Jake: It works.
Katrina:  补中
Katrina: Mid shot.
Jake: 紫藤来
Jake: Violet, come here.
Katrina:  我来我来我来
Katrina: I'm coming, I'm coming.
Katrina:  哎哪来的枪哈哈哈
Katrina: Hey, where did the gun come from? Haha.
Jake: 哎怎么这么多
Jake: Hey, why so many?
Shure:  完了要split了
Shure: Oh no, it's going to split.
Shure:  好全中
Shure: Alright, all hit.
Jake: 牛啊
Jake: Awesome.
Tasha: 还有吗
Tasha: Is there more?
Tasha: 还有是吧
Tasha: There's more, right?
Jake: 还有是吧
Jake: 还有克星还有吧
Jake: There's more, there's more, right?
Jake: 还有还有还有可心呢
Jake: There's more, where's Kexin?
Lucia:  还有吗哎又出来了
Lucia: Is there more? Hey, here it comes again.
Katrina:  还有哎
Katrina: There's more, hey.
Katrina:  几个币啊
Katrina: How many coins?
Katrina:  玩这么久可以
Katrina: Playing this long is good.
Jake: 呵一个一个一个
Jake: Haha, one by one.
Jake: 你这个带钻的你知道吧
Jake: You know this one has a diamond, right?
Lucia:  怎么回事啊哈哈哈
Lucia: What's happening? Haha.
Lucia:  那我就再把这一个打中呗
Lucia: Then I'll just hit this one.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 稳稳健
Jake: Steady and sure.
Katrina:  哇感觉可以
Katrina: Wow, feels good.
Jake: 耶
Jake: Yay.
Lucia:  耶
Lucia: Yay.
Lucia:  他应该会还有一局
Lucia: There should be one more round.
Lucia:  我怎么感觉
Lucia: I feel like...
Tasha:  没有了啊
Tasha: Is it over?
Jake: 没了没了就结束了
Jake: Yeah, it's over, it's done.
Jake: 好走吧
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Katrina:  我去买东西
Katrina: I'm going shopping.
Jake: 还有两个币
Jake: We still have two coins.
Jake: 两个币就钱生钱嘛
Jake: Two coins, money makes money.
Jake: 对对对对钱生钱
Jake: Yeah, yeah, money makes money.
Shure:  对钱生钱来
Shure: Right, money makes money.
Lucia:  要推币吗
Lucia: Do you want to push the coin?
Lucia:  推一个吧
Lucia: Push one.
Lucia:  找一个看哪个好推
Lucia: Find one that's easier to push.
Lucia:  这个这个卡住了这没开
Lucia: This one, this one is stuck, it's not open.
Lucia:  看别的吧
Lucia: Look at another one.
Katrina:  这有啥技巧吗
Katrina: Is there any trick to this?
Shure:  这这有人有人有人都
Shure: This, this one has someone, someone...
Lucia:  这个好像也没开吧
Lucia: This one doesn't seem open either.
Shure:  教你们技巧
Shure: I'll teach you a trick.
Lucia:  但这其实挺难的
Lucia: But this is actually quite hard.
Shure:  他他他伸进去
Shure: He, he, he puts it in.
Tasha:  伸进去时再放
Tasha: Put it in and then release.
Tasha:  放呀
Tasha: Release it.
Tasha:  放在哪了
Tasha: Where did you release it?
Lucia:  哦你按他才会释放好像
Lucia: Oh, you press it to release it, I think.
Tasha:  好石沉大海
Tasha: Alright, sinking into the sea.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  嗯再来一个我们
Shure: Hmm, let's do another one.
Jake: 这是蝴蝶效应
Jake: This is the butterfly effect.
Katrina:  这怎么玩啊
Katrina: How do you play this?
Shure:  对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah.
Lucia:  然后按一下他才会掉下来
Lucia: Then press it and it'll drop.
Lucia:  按微微按哈哈
Lucia: Press it gently, haha.
Shure:  okay放
Shure: Okay, release.
Katrina:  啊就这么玩吗
Katrina: Is this how you play it?
Jake: 啊
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia:  好像叠住了哈哈
Lucia: It seems stuck, haha.
Jake: 走吧哈哈哈
Jake: Let's go, haha.
Katrina:  就这么玩的吗
Katrina: Is this how you play it?
Katrina:  就掉下去
Katrina: It just drops down.
Jake: 走吧走吧
Jake: Let's go, let's go.
Lucia:  我记得小时候
Lucia: I remember when I was a kid...
Lucia:  这个推币机特别容易掉币
Lucia: This coin pusher is super easy to drop coins.
Lucia:  现在好像都把它改造的越来越不容易
Lucia: But now it seems they've modified it to make it harder.
Jake: 怎么还有拍一把
Jake: Why is there still a pat?
Tasha:  啊它掉下来了我刚刚把它拍下来了
Tasha: Ah, it fell down. I just patted it down.
Shure:  哎杨老板呢
Shure: Hey, where's Jake?
Katrina:  耶怎么到名创优品奥特曼呢
Katrina: Yay, how did we get to Miniso Ultraman?
其他人：对呀你要不要买那个
Others: Yeah, do you want to buy that?
Katrina:  卫生巾去好特卖买吧
Katrina: Let's go buy sanitary napkins at the sale.
其他人：好吧走
Others: Okay, let's go.
Katrina:  我去一趟好特卖我要买东西
Katrina: I'm going to the sale store, I need to buy something.
其他人：我也去
Others: I'll go too.
Katrina:  感觉好像好像要买什么
Katrina: Feels like I need to buy something.
Katrina:  洗脸巾和卫生巾
Katrina: Face towels and sanitary napkins.
Katrina:  洗脸巾和卫生
Katrina: Face towels and sanitary...
其他人：你大声说出来你要买什么然后进去就有对应
Others: Just say loudly what you want to buy and then go in and get it.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah.
Katrina:  买个小小的卫
Katrina: Buy a small sanitary...
其他人：要多长呢
Others: How long do you need?
Katrina:  买个日用的就行吧
Katrina: Just get a daytime one, I guess.
Shure:  这边会有很特价的东西是吗
Shure: Will there be special deals here?
其他人：这边
Others: Over here.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
其他人：这好像就行
Others: This seems fine.
Katrina:  也倒不是说很特别
Katrina: It's not really special.
Katrina:  就是它的保质期可能没那么长
Katrina: It's just that the shelf life might not be long.
Katrina:  但是很适合你
Katrina: But it's perfect for you.
Katrina:  马上要用
Katrina: You need it soon.
其他人：对然后
Others: Yeah, then...
Katrina:  洗脸巾它只有这种大包的嘛
Katrina: The face towels only come in big packs, right?
其他人：洗脸巾
Others: Face towels.
Katrina:  想增加我的它有没有压缩的
Katrina: I want more, do they have compressed ones?
Katrina:  买个两包吧
Katrina: Let's buy two packs.
其他人：嗯好
Others: Hmm, okay.
Katrina:  因为它那个
Katrina: Because...
其他人：你不要长的吗
Others: You don't need long ones?
Shure:  今晚要写毕设
Shure: I need to write my thesis tonight.
Katrina:  长的有
Katrina: There are long ones.
Katrina:  今晚什么
Katrina: Tonight, what?
Shure:  要写毕设
Shure: Need to write my thesis.
Katrina:  我也要写毕设
Katrina: I need to write my thesis too.
Shure:  嗯找自习室去吧哈哈哈
Shure: Hmm, let's find a study room, haha.
Katrina:  反正是
Katrina: Anyway, it's...
Katrina:  我问一下哈
Katrina: Let me ask.
Katrina:  你好有那种压缩的洗脸巾吗
Katrina: Hi, do you have those compressed face towels?
Katrina:  有一小袋一小没了
Katrina: There was a small bag, and now it's gone.
其他人：没有
Others: No, we don't.
Katrina:  那只能买大包了
Katrina: Then I have to buy the big pack.
Katrina:  买大包在一起用算了
Katrina: Let's just get the big pack and share.
Shure:  拿来厨房用纸
Shure: Use kitchen paper instead.
Katrina:  厨房用纸洗脸
Katrina: Use kitchen paper to wash your face?
Katrina:  我自己付吧这个无所谓
Katrina: I'll pay for it myself, it's no big deal.
Katrina:  付款
Katrina: Pay.
Tasha:  哦果然他们已经开始买了
Tasha: Oh, they already started buying.
Katrina:  不是买自己用的
Katrina: No, we're not buying for ourselves.
Shure:  没有没有没有
Shure: No, no, no.
Shure:  这这是一个
Shure: This is a...
Shure:  超级特价超市
Shure: Super discount supermarket.
Jake: 噢噢噢
Jake: Oh, oh, oh.
Katrina:  呀呀
Katrina: Yeah, yeah.
Jake: 没有那
Jake: There's no...
Katrina:  在这
Katrina: Over here.
其他人：要个袋吗
Others: Do you need a bag?
Katrina:  袋可以多大呀有小袋没
Katrina: How big can the bag be? Do you have small ones?
其他人：啊那没有最小的了
Others: Ah, we don't have the smallest ones.
Katrina:  行吧就这个
Katrina: Alright, this one then.
其他人：25块9
Others: 25.9 yuan.
Jake: 都有什么比较优秀的便宜的东西呢
Jake: What good and cheap things do you have here?
其他人：要小票不
Others: Do you need a receipt?
Katrina:  不用
Katrina: No, thanks.
Katrina:  OK接直接一个大袋子
Katrina: OK, just a big bag.
Katrina:  生活用品可以在好特卖买
Katrina: You can buy daily necessities at Hot Buy.
Katrina:  他们如果需要
Katrina: If they need.
Katrina:  太便宜啊两块钱
Katrina: So cheap, only two yuan.
其他人：啊是的
Others: Yeah, it is.
Katrina:  次我们学校对面有好特卖
Katrina: There's a Hot Buy opposite our school.
Katrina:  每次下课就来逛好特卖
Katrina: I go there every time after class.
Katrina:  这real好便宜啊
Katrina: This is really cheap.
Katrina:  so
Katrina: So...
Shure:  就比较有名的是吗
Shure: Is it quite famous?
Katrina:  cheap
Katrina: Cheap.
Lucia:  对但是当
Lucia: Yes, but when
Lucia:  当然也要看你
Lucia: Of course, it also depends on
Lucia:  就是本身葡萄的质量怎么样
Lucia: the quality of the grapes themselves.
Lucia:  但是就是莫斯卡托应该是产地
Lucia: But Moscato should be from
Lucia:  就这个地方应该不错了
Lucia: this place, which should be good.
Shure:  不是有效 2033年
Shure: Isn't it valid until 2033?
Lucia:  没事酒酒酒
Lucia: No worries, wine, wine, wine.
Lucia:  好像没有什么特别特殊的
Lucia: It doesn't seem particularly special.
Jake: 选一瓶
Shure:  今天晚上嘣一下好吧
Jake: 我们好啊
Jake: We're up for it.
Katrina:  就是可以搞点real不
Katrina: Can we get something real?
Katrina:  啊但是不想买
Katrina: But I don't want to buy it.
Alice:普通的还是强爽
Alice: Regular or strong?
Katrina:  没有
Katrina: No.
Katrina:  没找到普通的
Katrina: Couldn't find the regular one.
Katrina:  你看看普通的强爽算
Katrina: Check if the regular one is considered strong.
Shure:  这个素材得给AI看一下吧
Shure: This footage should be reviewed by AI.
Katrina:  他们说强爽的比较劣质
Katrina: They say the strong one is of poorer quality.
Shure:  来咱们39块钱今晚听个响
Shure: Let's spend 39 bucks and have some fun tonight.
Jake: 对我我我买的那个10个USB的充电器
Jake: Right, I bought that 10-port USB charger.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Oh.
Jake: 也3030多块钱一个
Jake: It was about 30 bucks each.
Jake: 响也没有就是一点都都充不上
Jake: It doesn't make any noise, can't charge at all.
Jake: 看起来挺牛逼
Jake: But it looks impressive.
Alice:起泡酒吗
Alice: Is it sparkling wine?
Shure:  对就可以嘣听个响
Jake: 这好歹能听个响
Jake: At least we can hear the pop.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Lucia:  我跟我朋友第一回开起泡酒的时候
Lucia: The first time my friend and I opened sparkling wine,
Lucia:  我们俩打开
Lucia: we opened it,
Lucia:  不知道接下来怎么处理
Lucia: and didn't know what to do next.
Lucia:  他就放在那
Lucia: So we just left it there.
Lucia:  就过一会他嘣哈哈哈
Lucia: After a while, it went pop, haha.
Alice:听个响
Alice: Hear the pop.
Jake: 延时听个响
Jake: Delayed pop.
Alice:虎邦辣椒酱
Alice: Tiger Hot Sauce.
Shure:  还有什么想买的吗Minasa
Shure: Anything else you want to buy, Minasa?
Jake: 还有啥好东西
Jake: Any other good stuff?
Shure:  你知道黄桃黄桃罐头吗
Shure: Do you know about canned yellow peaches?
Jake: 我知道治感冒的
Jake: I know a cure for colds.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Yeah.
Alice:哈哈哈啊
Alice: Hahaha!
Katrina:  买点小零食当那个
Katrina: Buy some snacks for that.
Jake: 是吗
Jake: Really?
Shure:  真的
Shure: Yes, really.
Katrina:  可以买什么
Katrina: What can I buy?
Shure:  在东北可以
Shure: In the northeast, you can.
Shure:  在别的地就不灵了
Shure: But it doesn't work elsewhere.
Alice:不一定
Alice: Not necessarily.
Shure:  这个东西
Shure: This thing...
Katrina:  买什么
Katrina: What should I buy?
Lucia:  有这样的吗
Lucia: Is there such a thing?
Jake: 就跟拜佛似的也治感冒
Jake: It's like praying to Buddha to cure a cold.
Alice:黄桃罐头
Alice: Canned yellow peaches.
Katrina:  哦哦黄桃罐头
Katrina: Oh, canned yellow peaches.
Shure:  就是这个东西
Shure: Exactly, that's it.
Jake: 拜菩萨也治感冒对
Jake: Praying to Bodhisattva also cures colds, right.
Shure:  非非常的违心
Shure: It's very hypocritical.
Alice:拜妈祖
Alice: Praying to Mazu.
Alice:福建的管用
Alice: It works in Fujian.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yes, yes, yes.
Katrina:  想买一包咪咪吃
Katrina: I want to buy a pack of Mimi snacks.
Katrina:  就当那个
Katrina: Just for that.
Katrina:  等早饭外卖
Katrina: While waiting for breakfast delivery.
Katrina:  的垫垫肚子那个
Katrina: To fill the stomach a bit.
Jake: 啊行行行
Jake: Ah, okay, okay.
Shure:  小零食可以
Shure: Snacks are fine.
Katrina:  对要是怕有的人胃不舒都行
Katrina: Yeah, in case some people's stomachs feel uncomfortable, it's fine.
Shure:  这不是野餐零食吗哈哈
Shure: Isn't this picnic snacks? Haha.
Katrina: 吃咪咪
Katrina: Eating Mimi snacks.
Tasha:  噔噔噔这个糖还挺好吃的
Tasha: Dun dun dun, this candy is pretty good.
Jake:好嘞
Jake: Alrighty.
Katrina: 拿呗
Katrina: Take it then.
Shure:  一块钱
Shure: One yuan.
Katrina: 一 块钱不在话下
Katrina: One yuan is no big deal.
Alice:什么玩意
Alice: What is it?
Tasha:  不在话下薄荷糖
Tasha: No big deal, peppermint candy.
Katrina:  一块钱
Katrina: One yuan.
Tasha:  你结过账了是吧
Tasha: You paid already, right?
Katrina:  我没有我买的是自己的东西
Katrina: I didn't, I bought my own stuff.
Katrina:  他们还没结呢
Katrina: They haven't finished yet.
Shure:  这样我们我们都给杨老板换
Shure: So, we'll all exchange it for Jake.
Shure:  换算成新币
Shure: Exchange it to new currency.
Katrina:  新加坡比
Katrina: Singapore dollars.
Alice:这样听起来就不心疼了哈哈
Alice: That way, it doesn't hurt as much, haha.
Jake: 这个太离谱了吧 5毛新
Katrina:  呃
Katrina: Uh...
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What is this?
Tasha:  什么
Tasha: What?
Jake: 5毛钱的新币
Jake: 50 cents in new currency.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah...
Jake: 什么东西
Jake: What is this?
Katrina:  五毛钱新加坡币
Katrina: 50 cents in Singapore dollars.
Shure:  3块9就5毛钱是吗
Shure: 3.9 is just 50 cents, right?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Shure:  你就除以5减3
Shure: Just divide by 5 and subtract 3.
Shure:  你大概除以5
Shure: Roughly divide by 5.
Shure:  然后再减去摸个0就对了
Shure: Then subtract a random zero, that's it.
Jake: 对给我报新币吧
Jake: Yeah, just report it in new currency.
Katrina:  啊
Katrina: Ah...
Jake: 你这多少钱这
Jake: How much is this?
Shure:  这个7新币
Shure: This is 7 Singapore dollars.
Katrina:  （歌词）月光下的人就是你
Katrina: (Lyrics) The person under the moonlight is you.
Katrina:  （歌词）红线划过
Katrina: (Lyrics) The red line crosses.
Jake: 七新币的酒
Jake: Seven Singapore dollars for the wine.
Jake: 这听这这也听
Jake: This sounds, this also sounds...
Jake: 呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe...
Shure:  听个响还能
Shure: Just for the sound, it can still...
Jake: 还来听个响
Jake: Still just for the sound.
Katrina:  走OK了
Katrina: Let's go, okay.
Lucia:  好像也还行
Lucia: Seems alright.
Lucia:  奥迪和丽豆里面应该有不少这个价格
Lucia: Audi and Lidl should have quite a few at this price.
Lucia:  你们那有奥迪和丽豆
Lucia: Do you have Audi and Lidl?
Katrina:  欧了欧了
Katrina: Okay, okay.
Lucia:  怎么买OK
Lucia: How do you buy, okay?
Jake: 但是七新币听起来就很便宜
Jake: But seven Singapore dollars sounds really cheap.
Katrina:  像花朵
Katrina: Like flowers.
Alice:这个牌子小啤酒
Alice: This brand of small beer.
Shure:  这这多少
Shure: How much is this?
Shure:  这不到1新币
Shure: This is less than 1 SGD.
Lucia:  媒体小铺
Lucia: Media shop.
Shure:  这这一袋那什么
Shure: This, this bag of what?
Lucia:  呃body shop是一个英国牌子
Lucia: Uh, Body Shop is a British brand.
Katrina:  这咪咪却不到一新币
Katrina: This candy is also less than 1 SGD.
Shure:  然后他
Shure: And then he...
Shure:  他还拿了一个不到两两毛新币的
Shure: He also took something less than 20 cents SGD.
Shure:  一个薄荷糖
Shure: A mint candy.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  哇以后就都给杨老板报新币
Shure: Wow, from now on we'll report everything to Jake in SGD.
Lucia:  那我买了瓶饮料可以吗
Lucia: Can I buy a drink then?
Lucia:  虽然我是自己喝
Lucia: Even though it's for myself.
Lucia:  不过大概也就5毛新币吧
Lucia: But it's probably around 50 cents SGD.
Tasha:  啊5毛新币
Tasha: Ah, 50 cents SGD.
Katrina: 可以
Katrina: Sure.
Shure:  他5毛钱
Shure: 50 cents.
Lucia:  5毛新币
Lucia: 50 cents SGD.
Tasha:  新币的换算比例是
Tasha: What's the conversion rate for SGD?
Shure:  除以5再抹个0
Shure: Divide by 5 and drop a zero.
Tasha: 除以5再抹个0
Tasha: Divide by 5 and drop a zero.
Shure:  对他说大概是5.3
Shure: Yeah, he said it's around 5.3.
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Jake: 多少新币
Jake: How much in SGD?
Jake: 10块
Jake: 10 bucks.
Katrina:  呵呵
Katrina: Hehe.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure:  52块4不到1新币
Shure: 52.4 bucks, less than 1 SGD.
Shure:  一个新币
Shure: 1 SGD.
Shure:  不行杨老板咱先别换算呵呵
Shure: No, Jake, let's not convert it for now. Hehe.
Jake: 来来来
Jake: Come on, come on.
Jake: 怎么付啊
Jake: How do we pay?
Katrina:  放我这袋里吧
Katrina: Put it in my bag.
Lucia:  这放会不会有点重啊
Lucia: Wouldn't it be a bit heavy if we put it here?
Katrina:  他提没关系
Katrina: He can carry it, no problem.
Lucia:  哦你提啊
Lucia: Oh, you're carrying it?
Lucia:  那那就放了
Lucia: Then I'll put it in.
Lucia:  那我就不客气了啊哈哈
Lucia: Then I won't be polite, haha.
Katrina:  哈哈哈没事
Katrina: Hahaha, it's fine.
Katrina:  走吧盒马在哪呢
Katrina: Let's go, where is Hema?
Jake: 来干正事吧
Jake: Let's get to work.
Jake: 行那正好
Jake: Alright, that's just right.
Jake: 正事能干一小时吗
Jake: Can you handle the main task for an hour?
Katrina:  号盒马往哪走啊
Katrina: Where does the good box go?
Katrina:  还要下去
Katrina: Does it need to go down?
Katrina:  哦谢谢
Katrina: Oh, thanks.
Katrina:  还要下去嘞
Katrina: It needs to go down further.
Shure:  还要下去吗
Shure: Does it need to go down further?
Jake: 你回去处理
Jake: You go back and handle it.
Jake: 充完电了就重来了
Jake: Recharge and then do it again.
Jake: 就不是这一波了
Jake: It won't be this round anymore.
Katrina:  1点点
Katrina: Just a bit.
Tasha:  好吧什么都不是
Tasha: Well, it's nothing.
其他人：啊好大一股那个这是什么味
Others: Oh, what a strong smell, what is it?
Katrina:  嗯那焦糖瓜子味
Katrina: Hmm, it's caramelized sunflower seeds.
Katrina:  就那种炒
Katrina: Like roasted.
Katrina:  那种铁锅炒瓜子
Katrina: Like roasted sunflower seeds in an iron pot.
其他人：抓几个榴莲蛋糕就跑
Others: Grab a few durian cakes and run.
Katrina:  嘿嘿你喜欢吃榴莲吗
Katrina: Hehe, do you like durian?
其他人：我不太喜欢吃
Others: I don't really like it.
Katrina:  要买烤煎烤肉的东西
Katrina: We need to buy stuff for grilling.
Shure:  是的走吧
Shure: Yeah, let's go.
Katrina:  提拉米蛋糕提拉米苏蛋糕
Katrina: Tiramisu cake, tiramisu cake.
Alice:哎呦炒货的味道好呛啊
Lucia: Oh wow, the smell of fried stuff is so strong.
Lucia:  哎咱是不是要推个车
Lucia: Hey, should we get a cart?
Katrina:  哎我们那天买那个小的胡椒粉了吗
Katrina: Did we buy that small pepper powder the other day?
Katrina:  好像买了哎
Katrina: Seems like we did.
Katrina:  这不是烤串吗
Katrina: Isn't this for grilling?
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
其他人：这不用交流了
Others: No need to discuss this.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
其他人：好吃吗
Others: Is it tasty?
Shure:  这显得我就很low
Shure: This makes me look very low.
Shure:  就没有用了你知道吗
Shure: It's useless, you know?
Jake: 签签签怎么整啊
Jake: How do we handle the signatures?
Shure:  这显得就很没用你知道吗
Shure: This makes me look very useless, you know?
Jake: 闲着用啊
Jake: Use it when idle.
Katrina:  嗯哼
Katrina: Uh-huh.
Jake: 那你干啥呀
Jake: So, what are you doing?
Lucia:  这有穿好的还有签
Lucia: There are some already skewered.
Alice:这不是有穿好的吗
Alice: Aren't these already skewered?
Lucia:  所有的问题都解决了
Lucia: All the issues are resolved.
Shure:  不咱们买点鸡翅
Shure: No, let's buy some chicken wings.
Shure:  我腌的鸡翅特别好吃
Shure: The chicken wings I marinate are really tasty.
Jake: 行整点整点
Jake: Sure, let's get some.
Katrina:  想要充分展示自己的能力
Katrina: I want to fully showcase my abilities.
Shure:  要拿吗也拿点这个
Shure: Should we get some of this too?
Jake: 拿点拿点拿点
Jake: Yeah, grab some.
Shure:  好吧就是咱们得保证一个饿不死的
Shure: Okay, we just need to make sure we don't starve.
Tasha:  羊肉
Tasha: Lamb.
Shure:  一个食食物
Shure: Some food.
Shure:  然后在
Shure: And then...
Katrina:  烤肉片
Katrina: Grilled meat slices.
其他人：烤肉片
Others: Grilled meat slices.
Lucia:  啊这是羊排吗
Lucia: Oh, are these lamb chops?
Shure:  我靠羊排
Shure: Wow, lamb chops.
Jake: 啥呀
Jake: What?
其他人：哇还有三三种拼盘
Others: Wow, there are three kinds of platters.
Tasha:  一个新币
Tasha: One new coin.
Tasha:  加起来一共两个新币
Tasha: Altogether, it's two new coins.
Alice:10
Alice: 10.
Alice:10点多
Alice: Over 10.
Jake: 买买两个新币在新加坡就有半根串
Jake: With two new coins in Singapore, you can get half a skewer.
Katrina:  真的吗这么贵
Katrina: Really? That expensive?
Jake: 哈哈真的是的
Jake: Haha, it really is.
Shure:  五十九十新币
Shure: Fifty, ninety new coins.
Shure:  你怎么算的哈哈
Shure: How did you calculate that? Haha.
Katrina:  一个新币换算成人民币是50块钱吗要
Katrina: One new coin equals 50 yuan, right?
Jake: 5对5.3
Jake: Yeah, about 5.3.
其他人：5 5块
Others: 5, 5 yuan.
Lucia:  哈 5比5点多
Lucia: Haha, more than 5 to 5.
Alice:5点多
Alice: More than 5.
Jake: 对大概一根串
Jake: Yeah, about one skewer.
Katrina:  5.3块
Katrina: 5.3 yuan.
Jake: 就牛肉串
Jake: Just a beef skewer.
Jake: 这种牛肉串
Jake: This kind of beef skewer.
Jake: 大概就是哎这种串
Jake: It's about, like this skewer.
Jake: 一一新币一个哦
Jake: One new coin each.
Jake: 一新币一串
Jake: One new coin per skewer.
Jake: 对一新币一串
Jake: Yeah, one new coin per skewer.
Katrina:  这也给你腌好了
Katrina: This is marinated for you.
Katrina:  怎么办呢
Katrina: What do we do?
Katrina:  这就是英雄无庸武之处啊
Katrina: This is what makes a hero stand out.
Shure:  不行我这不不需要不需要
Shure: No, I don't need, don't need this.
Shure:  咱们不用这些
Shure: We don't need these.
Shure:  这这些肯定不好吃
Shure: These definitely don't taste good.
Katrina:  你有自己独家配方来腌吗
Katrina: Do you have your own special marinade?
Katrina:  还是怎么
Katrina: Or what?
Shure:  是的祖传十八辈了已经
Shure: Yes, it's been passed down for 18 generations.
Katrina:  那你需要买什么调料吗
Katrina: Do you need to buy any spices?
Katrina:  那那那买这种买这种
Katrina: Then, let's buy this, buy this.
Jake: 哎肉买完了吗
Jake: Hey, did you buy the meat?
Jake: 还没开始呢
Jake: Not yet.
Katrina:  然后你拌你自己那个料
Katrina: Then you mix it with your own spice.
Lucia:  世界好癫
Lucia: The world is crazy.
Katrina:  什么东西啊
Katrina: What is this?
Lucia:  藤椒味的瓜子
Lucia: Prickly ash flavored sunflower seeds.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure:  那个很好吃
Shure: Those are delicious.
Katrina:  之前成交冰淇淋呢
Katrina: And prickly ash ice cream before?
Lucia:  啊真的还有藤椒冰淇淋啊
Lucia: Oh really, there's prickly ash ice cream?
Alice:啊真的
Alice: Oh really?
Shure:  巨好吃那个藤藤椒
Shure: It's super delicious, that prickly ash.
Katrina:  麦当劳这边出在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's has it, it's a Sichuan exclusive.
Lucia:  麦当劳是有什
Lucia: What does McDonald's have?
Lucia:  麦当劳你有什么心事吗
Lucia: McDonald's, do you have any worries?
Shure:  藤椒味的瓜子
Shure: Prickly ash flavored sunflower seeds.
Jake: 藤椒瓜藤椒冰淇淋
Jake: Prickly ash seeds, prickly ash ice cream.
Jake: 藤椒瓜子
Jake: Prickly ash seeds.
Katrina:  之前麦当劳出过在四川限定
Katrina: McDonald's had it before as a Sichuan exclusive.
Jake: 藤椒冰淇淋我靠
Jake: Prickly ash ice cream, oh my gosh.
Katrina:  就是还浇那个辣子油
Katrina: They even poured chili oil on it.
Katrina:  crazy
Katrina: Crazy.
Shure:  一斤多可以羊排
Shure: Over a pound of lamb chops.
Katrina:  这是什么呀羊排
Katrina: What is this? Lamb chops?
其他人：没事没事
Others: It's okay, it's okay.
Shure:  来我需要洋葱调料串
Shure: I need onions and spices for skewers.
Katrina:  洋葱
Katrina: Onions.
Jake: 块那个竹签怎么整
Jake: How do you handle the bamboo skewers?
Jake: 竹签竹签儿
Jake: Bamboo skewers, bamboo skewers.
Shure:  呃烤的那个
Shure: Uh, for grilling.
Katrina:  他就直接烤肉了
Katrina: He just went straight to grilling the meat.
Shure:  直接用这个
Shure: Just use this.
Shure:  然后不穿
Shure: And don't skewer it.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  咱们就烤片
Shure: We'll just grill the slices.
Shure:  然后腌好
Shure: Then marinate it.
Shure:  然后烤片可以吧
Shure: And then grill the slices, okay?
Jake: 行行行不要签了
Jake: Okay, okay, no skewering.
Alice:有那个夹子吗 翻面的
Alice: Do we have tongs to flip it?
Shure:  啊对好问题
Shure: Ah, good question.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice:沙子跟油
Alice: Sand and oil.
Shure:  好问题啊
Shure: Good question.
Katrina:  哎嘘嗯
Katrina: Eh, shh, hmm.
Shure:  油有刷子刷子也有刷刷子
Shure: We have oil and a brush for it.
Alice:孜然
Alice: Cumin.
其他人：应该有吧他那个烧烤套装
Others: We should have it in the BBQ set.
Shure:  你那天哎那谁呢
Shure: That day, hey, where's that person?
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 就是公寓
Jake: It's just in the apartment.
Jake: 在别墅里面有是吧
Jake: There's one in the villa, right?
其他人：应该有
Others: Should be.
Jake: 别墅有那夹子哈
Jake: The villa has the tongs, huh?
Shure:  啊OK
Shure: Ah, okay.
Alice:其实筷子也能
Alice: Actually, chopsticks would work too.
Shure:  我为什么要拎着他呀我靠
Shure: Why am I carrying this, damn it?
Shure:  我还傻傻地拎着他
Shure: I'm still foolishly carrying it.
Shure:  这时候就应该向他问一个问题
Shure: I should've asked him a question then.
Shure:  为什么我有一个车而不放进去
Shure: Why do I have a car but not put it inside?
Jake: 他花了多长时间意识到这个问题
Jake: How long did it take him to realize this?
Jake: 75
Jake: 75.
Lucia:  然后回国就会
Lucia: And then when I returned home,
Lucia:  哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:  所以我上次在上海的时候惊讶的发现
Lucia: So last time when I was in Shanghai, I was surprised to find that
Lucia:  上海东西竟然没比英国便宜多少
Lucia: things in Shanghai aren't much cheaper than in the UK.
Jake: 哦是啊是吧
Jake: Oh, really, right?
Lucia:  好多东西嗯
Lucia: A lot of things, hmm.
Lucia:  也可能我老去立冬和奥迪a
Lucia: Maybe because I often go to Lidong and Audi A.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:  这段删掉
Lucia: Cut this part out.
Lucia:  听起来我生活的好好悲惨
Lucia: It sounds like my life is so miserable.
Jake: 7块九两瓶
Jake: 7.90 for two bottles.
Lucia:  149的是加拿大雪蟹
Lucia: The 149 one is Canadian snow crab.
Lucia:  海参是39块9100克哎
Lucia: Sea cucumbers are 39.90 per 100 grams.
Lucia:  如果是冻鲜的那还挺便宜的嘞
Lucia: If they're frozen fresh, that's actually quite cheap.
Lucia:  暗示的眼神
Lucia: Hinting look.
Lucia:  没有没有
Lucia: No, no.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  我开玩笑的
Lucia: I'm just kidding.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha.
Jake: 我在想这
Jake: I was thinking...
Jake: 东西怎么吃
Jake: How to eat this stuff.
Jake: 今天还要做甜点
Jake: We also need to make dessert today.
Jake: 你要多少
Jake: How many do you need?
Tasha:  啊鸡蛋吗
Tasha: Ah, eggs?
Tasha:  一次甜品可能要10个鸡蛋吧
Tasha: Maybe 10 eggs for one batch of dessert.
Jake: 好嘞你还缺什么吗
Jake: Alright, do you need anything else?
Jake: 今儿
Jake: Today?
Jake: 今天做什么呀
Jake: What are we making today?
Tasha:  今天做什么
Tasha: What are we making today?
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Tasha:  都可以啊
Tasha: Anything's fine.
Tasha:  买点sweet drink吧
Tasha: Let's buy some sweet drinks.
Tasha:  他更像
Tasha: He's more like...
Jake: 动作太快了
Jake: Too fast.
Jake: 我怎么就树懒了呀
Jake: How did I become a sloth?
Lucia:  没有他是卡皮吧啦
Lucia: No, he's a capybara.
Jake: 那是啥
Jake: What's that?
Lucia:  情绪稳定啊
Lucia: Very calm.
Lucia:  你不知道这个梗吗
Lucia: You don't know this meme?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: No idea.
Lucia:  这是水豚
Lucia: It's a capybara.
Lucia:  是一种很可爱的动物
Lucia: It's a very cute animal.
Shure:  happy吧啦
Shure: Happy capybara.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:  然后他就是情绪特别稳定
Lucia: And it's super calm.
Lucia:  就是即使电脑的电线断了
Lucia: Even if the computer cable gets cut...
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Lucia:  他也能就是情绪稳定的按住
Lucia: He can also keep his emotions stable.
Shure:  肯定的爱
Shure: Definitely love.
Lucia:  直到把问题解决为止
Lucia: Until the problem is solved.
Tasha:  又买土豆
Tasha: Buying potatoes again.
其他人：不买土豆啊
Others: Don't buy potatoes.
Tasha:  买
Tasha: Buy.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Tasha:  烤点
Tasha: Roast some.
Shure:  想想啊咱们是7个人
Shure: Think about it, we are 7 people.
Jake: 这样你吃不了
Jake: You can't eat that much.
Jake: 其他人：
Jake: Others:
Shure:  是7个人吃是吧
Shure: Seven people will eat, right?
Tasha:  那要不要买那个烤料
Tasha: Should we buy that marinade?
Tasha:  烤烧烤料
Tasha: Barbecue marinade.
Shure:  是的我先算一下肉要多些
Shure: Yes, I'll calculate the amount of meat first.
Shure:  这么多鸡蛋
Shure: So many eggs.
Lucia:  这薇薇要做甜点要用
Lucia: Tasha needs them to make desserts.
Shure:  啊那一会借我两个
Shure: Ah, then lend me two later.
Tasha:  不借哈哈哈哈
Tasha: No lending, hahaha.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure:  要要腌的话会
Shure: If we marinate them, it'll be good.
Tasha:  要腌
Tasha: We need to marinate.
Tasha:  东西要用嗯
Tasha: We need ingredients, yeah.
Lucia:  哦OK
Lucia: Oh, OK.
Lucia:  我以为要往上面裹汁嘞
Lucia: I thought we were just coating it with sauce.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Shure:  对洋葱
Shure: Yes, onions.
Tasha:  洋葱在这里就有
Tasha: We have onions here.
Shure:  我先算算一下肉的肉的量
Shure: Let me calculate the amount of meat first.
Alice:在那呢
Alice: It's over there.
Alice:但是他你要不
Alice: But if you don't...
Jake: 哦真远
Jake: Oh, it's so far.
Alice:买那个洋葱吧
Alice: Buy that onion.
Shure:  我要紫皮洋葱
Shure: I want red onions.
Jake: 这个很紫啊
Jake: This one is very red.
Jake: 这边啊
Jake: Over here.
Alice:这个有机的
Alice: This one is organic.
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha:  没关系我们就吃贵的
Tasha: It's okay, we'll just eat the expensive one.
Lucia:  要大的还是小的
Lucia: Do you want the big ones or the small ones?
Jake: 有机多少钱
Jake: How much is the organic one?
Tasha:  我觉得要小的比较
Tasha: I think the small ones are better.
Tasha:  呃要三个小的比较好
Tasha: Uh, three small ones would be best.
Tasha:  这样子的话就不会浪费
Tasha: That way, we won't waste any.
Lucia:  400克5块9 这个是那个类
Lucia: 400 grams for 5.9. This is the one.
Jake: 这多少钱
Jake: How much is this?
Lucia:  如果我没看错
Lucia: If I read it right.
Shure:  一新币这个
Shure: One dollar for this.
Jake: 这多少钱半新币
Jake: How much is this? Half a dollar?
Jake: 哈哈啊就差一块钱
Jake: Haha, just one dollar off.
Shure:  啊但是这个比那个轻 100克
Shure: Yeah, but this is 100 grams lighter.
Shure:  够了这些
Shure: This is enough.
Shure:  然后肉的话一斤一斤半
Shure: And for the meat, one and a half pounds.
Alice:需要土豆什么吗
Alice: Do we need potatoes or anything?
Alice:土豆生菜
Alice: Potatoes, lettuce?
Shure:  然后底下那些串
Shure: And those skewers.
Alice:生菜
Alice: Lettuce.
Alice:生菜需要吗
Alice: Do we need lettuce?
Alice:生菜在那呢
Alice: The lettuce is over there.
Jake: 我们回去之后
Jake: After we go back.
Jake: 呃哪一个小时用来给我传数据了
Jake: Uh, which hour is for sending me the data?
Jake: 立即传啊
Jake: Send it right away.
Shure:  对然后因为我们要处理这些的
Shure: Yeah, because we need to process it.
Jake: OK那对对是的
Jake: OK, yeah, right.
Jake: 所以回去之后先放冰箱就给我传是吗
Jake: So after we go back, put it in the fridge first, then send it to me, right?
Jake: 要放冰箱吗
Jake: Does it need to go in the fridge?
Shure:  对也其实也
Shure: Yeah, actually, it...
Lucia:  放冰箱要拍吗
Lucia: Do we need to take a picture of it in the fridge?
Jake: 要拍放一下吧放一下吧
Jake: Yeah, take a picture, then put it in.
Lucia:  那就放啊
Lucia: Then just put it in.
Jake: 放下等着然后开始切是吧
Jake: Put it in, wait, then start cutting, right?
Shure:  咱们7个人吧不是
Shure: We have seven people, right?
Lucia:  那土豆也算是一种主食
Lucia: Potatoes are also a staple food.
Lucia:  因为主要主要成分是淀粉对吧
Lucia: Because the main component is starch, right?
Alice:土豆三个够吗
Alice: Are three potatoes enough?
Lucia:  强词夺理
Lucia: That's just arguing.
Lucia:  哈哈哈哈哈哈对
Lucia: Hahahahaha, yeah.
Jake: 土豆泥对吧
Jake: Mashed potatoes, right?
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 面包片做早饭是吧
Jake: Bread for breakfast, right?
Jake: 明明天做个早饭吧
Jake: Mingming, let's make breakfast tomorrow.
其他人：烤烤着好吃
Others: Toasting it tastes better.
Jake: 啊好好
Jake: Oh, okay.
Jake: 哈哈哈现在点菜
Jake: Hahaha, now let's order food.
Jake: 其实点菜还要吃什么烧烤
Jake: Actually, what else should we get besides barbecue?
Katrina:  有水果吗
Katrina: Do we have any fruit?
Katrina:  我们水果吃完了好像都
Katrina: I think we finished all the fruit.
Alice:没有
Alice: No, we don't.
Katrina:  再买一个
Katrina: Let's buy some more.
Lucia:  那我们要不买买点什么水果好啊
Lucia: What kind of fruit should we get?
Katrina:  买点好剥的
Katrina: Let's get something easy to peel.
Katrina:  橘子还有那个阳光玫瑰那个
Katrina: Oranges, and those Shine Muscat grapes.
Lucia:  哎我们之前是买了一颗蓝莓
Lucia: Didn't we buy some blueberries before?
Lucia:  还在冰箱里
Lucia: They're still in the fridge.
Lucia:  今天今天
Lucia: Today, today...
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
Shure:  再再来两个
Shure: Let's get two more.
Lucia:  那今天得把它吃掉
Lucia: We need to finish them today.
Lucia:  不然容易坏
Lucia: Otherwise, they'll go bad.
Katrina:  啊好
Katrina: Ah, okay.
Lucia:  然后我们再补充一点水果
Lucia: Then we can buy some more fruit.
Shure:  好够了肯定够了
Shure: Okay, that's definitely enough.
Katrina:  草莓呢也得吃
Katrina: We also need to eat the strawberries.
Lucia:  我都可我都可
Lucia: I can, I can...
Katrina:  是不是还有一盒
Katrina: Do we still have one box left?
Alice:草莓有一盒那个要干嘛
Alice: We have one box of strawberries, what should we do with them?
Alice:做做做
Alice: Make, make, make...
Katrina:  要不要来一箱北冰洋
Katrina: Should we get a case of Arctic Ocean soda?
Shure:  然后调料
Shure: And some condiments.
Katrina:  北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Shure:  来一打
Shure: Let's get a dozen.
Katrina:  北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Shure:  啤酒配烤肉吗
Shure: Beer with barbecue?
Katrina:  no北冰洋配烤肉
Katrina: No, Arctic Ocean soda with barbecue.
Katrina:  我们小孩吃
Katrina: For the kids.
Shure:  还小孩呢
Shure: Still kids?
Shure:  到法定结
Shure: You've reached...
Shure:  婚年龄了吧
Shure: The legal marriage age, right?
Shure:  我还没到呢
Shure: I haven't reached it yet.
Katrina:  这这
Katrina: This this...
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: Do you know?
Shure:  我那天还试了一下
Shure: I even tried it the other day.
Katrina:  你是去民政局了
Katrina: Did you go to the civil affairs bureau?
Shure:  不我是民政局预约i am不行
Shure: No, I made an appointment at the civil affairs bureau, but it didn't work out.
Katrina:  哎呀我去拿水果去
Katrina: Ah, I'll go get some fruit.
Katrina: （歌词） 鲜花落后
Katrina: (Singing) After the flowers fall...
Jake: 哈哈哈还行吧
Jake: Hahaha, not bad.
Katrina:  偷偷买了一个冰淇
Katrina: Secretly bought an ice cream.
Jake: 这个多少钱
Jake: How much was this?
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me see.
其他人：可以
Others: It's okay.
Katrina:  没人知道
Katrina: No one knows.
Katrina:  哈哈
Katrina: Haha.
Katrina:  笑什么
Katrina: What's so funny?
Lucia:  是是那天那个1,600块钱的帝王蟹吗
Lucia: Is it that 1,600 yuan king crab from that day?
Jake: 哈哈哈哈不是
Jake: Hahahaha, no.
Lucia:  还是啥
Lucia: Or what?
Shure:  哎波龙才469啊
Shure: Hey, the lobster was only 469 yuan.
Shure:  换算除5的话不到100新币
Shure: When you convert it, it's less than 100 Singapore dollars.
Jake: 波龙在波士顿就十十美元
Jake: Lobster in Boston is just ten dollars.
Jake: 10美元一只
Jake: Ten dollars each.
Jake: 当时吃了一周就天天的买
Jake: We ate it for a week straight, buying it every day.
Jake: 然后吃腻了
Jake: Then we got tired of it.
Jake: 哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Lucia:  听起来很爽的亚子
Lucia: Sounds pretty awesome.
Jake: 是的是的
Jake: Yes, yes.
Lucia:  伦敦大概15磅
Lucia: In London, it's about 15 pounds.
Lucia:  啊我喜欢这个
Lucia: Ah, I like this.
Shure:  茴香和孜然是一个东西吗
Shure: Is fennel and cumin the same thing?
Jake: 还缺什么呀
Jake: What else is missing?
Jake: 明早你们做个早饭吧
Jake: You guys make breakfast tomorrow morning.
Tasha:  嗯
Tasha: Hmm.
Jake: 啊明早会做
Jake: Ah, will you make it tomorrow morning?
Jake: 明天明早做早饭吧
Jake: Tomorrow morning, make breakfast.
Tasha:  可以啊
Tasha: Sure.
Lucia:  可以做我们刚才是不是买了面包
Lucia: We can make it. Didn't we buy bread earlier?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:  还是怎么回事来着
Lucia: Or what was it?
Jake: 对面包是要烤的啊还没对
Jake: Yes, the bread needs to be toasted, right.
Alice:面包还没买呢
Alice: We haven't bought the bread yet.
Katrina:  买个面包搞点番茄酱就行了
Katrina: Just buy some bread and get some ketchup.
Tasha:  后再买点生菜
Tasha: Then get some lettuce too.
Tasha:  直接做个三明治
Tasha: We can just make a sandwich.
Alice:生菜有但是不知道够不够
Alice: We have lettuce, but I'm not sure if it's enough.
Katrina:  hamburger
Katrina: Hamburger.
Katrina:  hamburger选手在
Katrina: The hamburger contestant is here.
Jake: 明天就在
Jake: Tomorrow, we'll be here.
Jake: 就就在屋里待着了
Jake: We'll just stay in the house.
Katrina:  可以啊
Katrina: Sounds good.
Jake: 跳跳舞什么的
Jake: Maybe dance or something.
Jake: 然后如果快递到了就整一整
Jake: And if the delivery arrives, we'll sort it out.
Katrina:  对明天主要快递会很多
Katrina: Yes, there will be a lot of deliveries tomorrow.
Lucia:  到这个我的快递为什么还没到
Lucia: Why hasn't my delivery arrived yet?
Lucia:  我在京东上买的东西
Lucia: I bought stuff on JD.com.
Lucia:  应该今天到啊
Lucia: It should've arrived today.
Jake: 好行行好的
Jake: Okay, got it, got it.
Jake: 好可以好
Jake: Alright, that's good.
Katrina:  你要回去啊
Katrina: Are you going back?
其他人：我要赶紧回别墅拿东西
Others: I need to quickly go back to the villa to get something.
Katrina:  打卡吗
Katrina: To clock in?
其他人：然后再回去
Others: And then come back.
Katrina:  啊那你好折腾
Katrina: Ah, you're really busy.
Katrina:  拜拜拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye, bye-bye.
Shure:  哪里有
Shure: Where is...
Jake: 周日见周日来是吧
Jake: See you on Sunday, you're coming on Sunday, right?
Shure:  拜拜哦
Shure: Bye-bye.
其他人：周日周日见
Others: See you on Sunday.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Katrina:  好拜拜
Katrina: Okay, bye-bye.
Shure:  那是咱们是6个人啊
Shure: So, there are six of us?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 怎么
Jake: What?
Shure:  那没事吃不了
Shure: It's fine, we won't finish it.
Lucia:  有什么要拿的吗
Lucia: Is there anything we need to take?
Shure:  周日再弄吧
Shure: Let's do it on Sunday.
Jake: 对可以好
Jake: Yes, that's good.
Shure:  没事了没事
Shure: It's all good, no problem.
其他人：OK没事了
Others: Okay, no problem.
Jake: 拜拜
Jake: Bye-bye.
Katrina:  拜拜
Katrina: Bye-bye
Shure:  哇你还买冰淇淋了
Shure: Wow, you even bought ice cream.
Katrina:  偷偷的夹带私货哈哈
Katrina: Secretly sneaked it in, haha.
Shure:  孜然哥我们还需要孜然
Shure: We still need cumin, man.
Katrina:  这是什么呀
Katrina: What's this?
Katrina:  这不是孜然吗
Katrina: Isn't this cumin?
Katrina:  这是孜然啊
Katrina: This is cumin, right?
Shure:  这是孜然粉
Shure: This is cumin powder.
Shure:  不是孜然
Shure: Not cumin.
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Alice:我们还有白胡椒
Alice: We also have white pepper.
Katrina:  孜然和孜然粉有什么区别
Katrina: What's the difference between cumin and cumin powder?
Shure:  粒儿的和粉它其实不太一样
Shure: The seeds and the powder are actually different.
Lucia:  我喜欢这个
Lucia: I like this.
Alice:这是啥辣椒粉辣椒面
Alice: What's this? Chili powder or chili flakes?
Katrina:  辣椒面
Katrina: Chili flakes.
Katrina:  买面包了吗
Katrina: Did you buy bread?
Katrina:  没有是吧
Katrina: No, right?
Alice:还没买面包呢
Alice: Haven't bought bread yet.
Shure:  行那再买点面面包
Shure: Okay, let's buy some bread.
Katrina:  买个面包个番茄酱
Katrina: Buy some bread and ketchup.
Shure:  然后剩下的没有了就外卖一下吧
Shure: And if there's nothing else, let's just order takeout.
Katrina:  OK走吧
Katrina: OK, let's go.
Katrina:  面包
Katrina: Bread.
Katrina:  面包在哪
Katrina: Where's the bread?
Katrina:  是不是在那方向
Katrina: Is it that way?
Shure:  有上次有一个什么烘焙的那地方
Shure: Last time, there was a bakery over there.
Katrina:  然后我们最大的花销就是吃
Katrina: Our biggest expense is food.
Shure:  住更贵一点
Shure: Housing is more expensive.
Jake: 哈哈哈建立不了关联
Jake: Haha, can't establish a connection.
Jake: 关联建立失败
Jake: Connection failed.
Katrina:  哎这是吃饭点
Katrina: Hey, it's a dining area.
Katrina:  人家烘焙区呢
Katrina: Where's the bakery section?
Katrina:  上次来的盒马没有这种店哎
Katrina: There wasn't such a store at Hema last time.
Alice:这应该不是
Alice: This shouldn't be it.
Lucia:  尝试一下建立别的关联
Lucia: Try to establish another connection.
Lucia:  那天还看到什么了
Lucia: What else did you see that day?
Katrina:  盒马跟什么外包了吗
Katrina: Did Hema outsource anything?
Katrina:  这是成就餐区了
Katrina: This turned into a dining area.
Katrina:  走那边吧
Katrina: Let's go that way.
Katrina:  走那边绕回去什么
Katrina: Go around that way and come back or something.
Alice:面食之类的不知道好像不是那种
Alice: Things like noodles, I don't know, it doesn't seem like that kind.
Katrina:  不是不是这是玉米哎也可以蒸玉米哈
Katrina: No, no, this is corn. Hey, we can steam corn too.
Katrina:  玉米是不是得往锅里蒸啊
Katrina: Should we steam the corn in a pot?
Katrina:  不能放微波炉吧
Katrina: We can't put it in the microwave, right?
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Alice:但我们有锅
Alice: But we have a pot.
Katrina:  特别没有生活常识
Katrina: I have no common sense at all.
Shure:  其实
Shure: Actually...
Katrina:  哎烘焙区呢
Katrina: Hey, where's the baking section?
Shure:  对一会回去的路上咱们先把碳点着
Shure: Yeah, on our way back, let's light the charcoal first.
Katrina:  有点碳的东西吗
Katrina: Do we have anything to light the charcoal?
Katrina:  火打火
Katrina: Fire, lighter.
Alice:火枪
Alice: Blowtorch.
Katrina:  呵呵
Katrina: Haha.
Alice:没有
Alice:一般卖碳的地方是不是会有那个啊
Alice: Normally, places that sell charcoal have those, right?
Shure:  看的地方有
Shure: Some places do.
Katrina:  刷油的刷子和油有吗
Katrina: Do we have brushes and oil for basting?
Katrina:  这可以问管家吗
Katrina: Can we ask the housekeeper for that?
Alice:只要有个打火机就行了
Alice: As long as we have a lighter, it's fine.
Shure:  也可以
Shure: That works too.
Alice:火枪里面也可以不用
Alice: We don't necessarily need a blowtorch.
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh.
Shure:  刚刚那会好像你们你们先往那边走
Shure: Just now, you guys walked that way.
Alice:你想要酸奶吗
Alice: Do you want yogurt?
Lucia:  我都可以
Lucia: I'm fine with anything.
Katrina:  可以搞这种小瓶酸奶放冰箱里
Katrina: We can get these small bottles of yogurt and put them in the fridge.
Katrina:  大家想喝就喝
Katrina: Drink them whenever you want.
Jake: 这哪家呀
Jake: Which brand is this?
Lucia:  我是一个都可以的树懒
Lucia: I'm a sloth, I'm good with anything.
Katrina: 哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Lucia:  小瓶那像这种
Lucia: The small bottles, like these.
Lucia:  然后可以分装
Lucia: Then we can portion them.
Jake: 最小的
Jake: The smallest one.
Lucia:  我感觉这玩意好像也不便宜
Lucia: I feel like this isn't cheap either.
Katrina: 简爱
Katrina: Jian'ai.
Jake: 嗯呃简爱是哪个
Jake: Hmm, which one is Jian'ai?
Katrina:  牌子买的小小装的
Katrina: It's a brand, the small packaged ones.
Jake: 他那个长的是这个
Jake: Does it look like this one?
Jake: 玩是什么牌子呀
Jake: What brand is it?
其他人：乐纯
Others: Lechun
Katrina:  下面这个吗
Katrina: Is it the one below?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh
其他人：对拌坚果吃的
Others: Yes, mix it with nuts.
Jake: 叫叫啥
Jake: What's it called?
其他人：0蔗糖的原价卖39块9的
Others: It's sugar-free, originally priced at 39.9.
Jake: 有牌子吗
Jake: Does it have a brand?
其他人：现在22块9促销的
Others: Now it's on sale for 22.9.
Jake: 我靠认不得
Jake: Damn, I don't recognize it.
其他人：这一排就便宜16块钱呢
Others: This whole row is only 16.
Katrina:  这这3个
Katrina: These three?
Katrina:  3个太不划算了吧
Katrina: Three is not a good deal, right?
Katrina:  我建议是拿这种小小的
Katrina: I suggest getting these small ones.
Katrina:  我们想喝就喝那种
Katrina: We can drink them whenever we want.
Katrina:  这个两组19块9
Katrina: Two sets for 19.9.
Katrina:  啥意思啊
Katrina: What does that mean?
其他人：就是i这些就是19块9
Others: These are 19.9 each.
Katrina:  啊就是这这19块9
Katrina: Oh, so these are 19.9?